[Music]
you post photos of your children yes and
you feel very free like you know if they
if if they're committing some kind of
transgression you'll take a photo of
them and yeah and it goes on the
internet I figure I'll be dead in a
couple years so it doesn't matter but no
I I try and capture some of the humor
you know that's what social media is for
and so I've captured my kids doing some
pretty ridiculous stuff but it seems
like it's usually just them you know
falling asleep at the dinner table stuff
like that so if one of you it's like a
fraternity it's one of your kids falls
asleep huge step I think we brought some
I believe they spiked the cake or
something well Mr Bond is that okay it
looks like he's eating directly and
ambiens
that was you know after birthday cake
and I took that photo again here he's
eating some bowtie pasta right that'll
do it and a colouring book by the way I
should clarify he has been awake at some
point certain boy will you post this and
people are like you should put that
child in the bed
you